si vous aussi vous voulez avoir cette
icône sans votre iphone et vous la péter
devant vos potes vous allez voir c'est
très facile dans le mode concentration
vous venez créer un nouveau mode vous
choisissez un nom une couleur et une
icône cette icône justement celle qui
s'affichera en eau sur votre iphone
alors moi je choisir des ciseaux vous
pouvez choisir tout ce que vous voulez
vous choisissez ensuite les personnes
qui pourront vous contacter quand vous
aurez activé ce mode alors pensé à
mettre tout le monde sans quoi elles ne
pourraient pas vous contacter ben oui ça
reste comme un mode concentration par
défaut et vous faites la même chose avec
les applications vous n'avez plus qu'à
activer le mode concentration que vous
venez de créer vous verrez cette icône
qui vont s'afficher en haut de votre
iphone alors ça sert à rien mais c'est
la classe